meet dr vivek morthy he's the united
states surgeon general what does that
mean and what does he do the surgeon
general is sometimes called the nation's
doctor he or she is the government's
primary spokesperson
on all matters of public health i'm kind
of a big deal recently i was invited to
trek down to dc
and meet with dr morty to ask him some
of my most burning questions
surgeon general thank you so much for
joining us on the youtube channel we
very much appreciate your time we know
it's limited we know you're doing
some amazing things here at the white
house actually all across the united
states
because your position really covers all
of the us can you tell us a little bit
about that well absolutely and dr mike
it's so great to be with you today i'm
glad we're having this conversation
you know i'm privileged to serve as
sergeant general it's a job i was uh
fortunate to have before in the obama
administration and the job of the
surgeon general is really to provide
the country with the best possible
information based on science
so they can make good decisions about
their health and during my time mr
general one of my hopes is
that we can first and foremost you know
turn this pandemic around and that's why
i want to do everything i can
to make sure people know the facts about
the vaccine so they can get vaccinated
protect themselves and their families
but i also want us to focus and have a
conversation
about some of the other challenges that
we're facing that have been made worse
by covet
mental health substance use disorders
and more broadly challenges around
equity
everyone knows the position of surgeon
general for
its pop culture meaning of being on
labels tobacco products
alcohol products what's the next label
do we have one is it going to be social
media vaping is there one in the works
that perhaps the youtube community isn't
aware of yet well
there's no label in the works at the
moment but
there are things that that i'm worried
about that i think that we do need to
raise a flag about
in 2016 when our surgeon general we
actually issued
a report about e-cigarettes in you okay
recognizing that
you know for many uh children uh
millions in fact if kids are under that
this was becoming a way through which
they were
developing independence actually on
nicotine and uh
there are other areas also where parents
are increasingly raising concerns
to our office and others around for
example social media and
wondering what are the impacts on the
mental health of my children and i
should just say lastly you know
when it comes to technology platforms
there's also a profound challenge we
have with misinformation
right now we see that in rampant with
covet
throughout this pandemic particularly
now with the vaccines
and so one question that you know we've
got to ask is what's your responsibility
to make sure
that there's accurate information that
users are getting how do you
see yourself playing a role as surgeon
general to guide this
conversation movement towards taking
mental health seriously
talking about it responsibly what can we
do from a national perspective here on
this
well it's such an important question and
i think we actually have to tackle it on
several fronts because we have actually
even pre-pandemic
been really challenged in the field of
mental health we've struggled with
access to mental health care as you know
in terms of mental health workforce
we just don't have enough people to
provide good care but we're also not
doing enough when it comes to prevention
there are programs that we could invest
in right now
in schools across our country that would
help build a foundation
uh for strong mental health and
emotional well-being in our kids but
we're just not
investing there but finally on a
cultural level we have to change how we
think as a country as a society about
mental health
we have to see it as an equal part of
health but also not as something
to be ashamed of if we're struggling
with our mental health i've also
read and heard that you have a strong
passion for advocating for the mental
health of providers
nurses doctors pharmacists lab techs
all the people who've been on the front
lines throughout this pandemic
what can we do to help those individuals
because like right now
obviously there are improvements being
made there's decreased hospitalizations
i have a few er colleagues who told me
over their last three four shifts they
haven't seen a single covet patient
which is amazing what do we say to those
individuals who have been on the front
lines
how do we help them how do we give them
assistance with still taking into
consideration that this stigma applies
to all of us yeah and
in in our house of medicine this stigma
is substantial
and i think you and i probably can both
recall days from our training
when it was very clear that strength was
associated with things like
how many hours you could stay up how
many patients you could admit
how many papers you could recall during
morning report
or ultimately how many papers you
published but
you know when was the last time that we
heard about a doctor
or a nurse being promoted for their
compassionate and empathetic care
of a patient you don't see that kind of
movement on the academic ladder often
enough
and so i think part of what we have to
do in the profession is recognize that
we've got to shift our culture so
that people who are struggling in our
profession can actually step forward
can get help my primary identity is
still that of
of a doctor and i think about our
colleagues in medicine
doctors nurses pharmacists and others
who have been on the front lines
providing care
who were already struggling before the
pandemic and i worry about the burnout
that we are seeing increase in that
population
because the truth is we need to serve
those who have been serving us we got to
take care
of our of our health care providers we
also know
that if they burn out at the rates that
we're seeing now we are not only going
to have a problem if there's a
resurgence in coping we will have
problems caring for people
for routine uh medical issues as well
you also fall into this category into
this group
right you're a physician uh you
experience burnout i'm sure just like
every other human
what's your strategy for battling that
that's a really good question and you
know i'm
i'm a work in progress you know i have
my days where i struggle as well
with burnout and with exhaustion and
and it's tough you know it goes in
cycles but there are a few things that i
found are very important to me
uh you know one is to make sure that i'm
anchoring myself
in relationships uh relationships in
particular with friends and family
you know when you get burned out
ironically the what gets pushed aside
often are your relationships
as you start to you know feel like you
have less energy interact with other
people to reach out to other people
uh you might feel more grumpy or or or
crabby around them as i often do
and that actually can push uh people
away but making sure for me that i'm
spending some time each day even if it's
just 15 minutes
uh talking to people i care about ask
them how they're doing
uh listening to them that's an important
source of healing the second thing that
i've
i've got to do is is to make sure that i
am also
pacing myself that i'm taking breaks
when i can and during those breaks that
i'm doing something that renews me and
finally one last thing which is
gratitude which i find is an
extraordinarily
powerful renewing source of energy
i try to keep a few moments at the end
of each day to just remember
what i'm grateful for i was honestly not
very good at doing that until i had kids
and because of my wife who is far more
resilient
and thoughtful than i am she began doing
this exercise with our children at the
end of each day
asking them what they were grateful for
and that's actually inspired me to do
that and it's been a really powerful
way to reconnect with meaning and to
feel renewed
after a long difficult day absolutely
i'm so glad you have that because
we have this age of information overload
constant anxiety whether it's from our
jobs our phones our family members
our friends and we start losing focus of
what brings us true fulfillment which is
the extrinsic factors you mentioned
these deep relationships meaning
gratitude uh even looking forward to the
future even it's for the next day for
something special
um the pandemic has really taken that
away from us you know for me the way
that i would cope with some of my
stressors pre-pandemic
was looking forward to the future so
when i was doing my residency working a
long icu shift i would say
oh next month i have less days that i'm
working so i would look forward to that
pandemic took that away another thing
that it took away was the relationships
you just mentioned
and it's created true loneliness even
coming out of the pandemic now as
some of the lockdowns ease in the united
states we're still experiencing
loneliness and i know that's a subject
that's really important to you as well
what can we do if we are having some
layers of anxiety
in sort of coming together again this is
such an important uh
point and this is one of the great costs
of the pandemic that's invisible
the loneliness and isolation that's
resulted from it it's very
understandable some people will feel
anxious
we're all going to move at different
paces and so the first thing is just to
recognize that
to not judge yourself but also not judge
others if they're going at a different
pace than you are
but the other piece is just to remember
here is that
if we've learned one thing from this
pandemic it's that our relationships
really do matter
they are how we get through tough times
they're also what sustains us
during times of stress and so in the way
that makes
most sense to you that feels most
comfortable for you just start reaching
out
to friends maybe it's a phone call maybe
it's a video call
maybe it's an outdoor walk if that's
what you feel more comfortable with or
maybe it's an indoor meal
that you share together like old times
but building that into your
into your days and into your weeks is
incredibly important because
all of us have been through trauma
together we may have experienced this
pandemic in different ways but we've all
experienced it deeply
and trauma requires healing one of the
most powerful source of healing that we
have
are our relationships with one another
and finally just remember
that means also that you can be a
powerful source of healing in someone
else's life
you don't need to have an md behind your
name or an rn
to be a healer you just need to be able
to show up in someone's life
to listen openly to them to be fully
present
and through that you can remind them
that they matter
that they're seen that they're
understood and that is where the real
healing begins
you have uh seven and a half million or
just under seven and a half million
viewers watching you subscribers
watching you
what's the message you want to leave
them off about their health or perhaps
about your second term as surgeon
general well
first i just want to thank everyone for
for tuning in and i just want to say
look at this moment where we're all
struggling through this pandemic
one of the most important things that
you can do to protect yourself protect
your family
is to get vaccinated and to make sure
that people around you
are get vaccinated too it is our
clearest path to getting back to our way
of life
and beyond this look we do have big
challenges we've got to take on
maybe you felt depressed maybe you're
feeling anxious about returning
uh to a post-pandemic life this is
something that's not
uncommon and so if you're feeling any of
these these things i want you to know
that you're not alone
once you know it doesn't mean that
you're broken in some way what it means
is that you're a human being having a
very
human experience
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you